was greeted in tel aviv by israeli prime
minister ya lapid biden will also meet
with palestinian leaders in the occupied
west bank he has been a steadfast
supporter of israel for decades and is
expected to face questions also about
the killing of palestinian-american
journalist shireen abu aklar kimberly
halkin has this report
the purpose of u.s president joe biden's
trip to israel in saudi arabia is not
entirely apparent
but just moments after landing in tel
aviv biden made clear what he would not
achieve
we'll discuss
my continued support
even though i know it's not a near term
a two-state
solution that remains it might be the
best way to ensure the future of equal
measure of freedom prosperity and
democracy
for israelis and palestinians alike
this admission is likely to enrage
palestinians as biden is set to meet
with the head of the palestinian
authority mahmoud abbas on friday
palestinians are pushing for the u.s to
reopen its consulate in occupied east
jerusalem limit settlement expansion and
press israel for accountability in the
killing of al jazeera journalist shirin
abu akhley who is a u.s citizen
such goals are a challenge with
elections looming future israeli
leadership is uncertain on thursday
biden meets with caretaker prime
minister yar lapid and conservative
hardliner former leader benjamin
netanyahu who may be plotting a comeback
that makes the white house aim of
improving israeli saudi security ties to
counter chinese russian and iranian
influence in the region
much more difficult
the u.s administration and its president
want to visit the region with a
motivation to create peace and stability
they should revise their foreign and
regional policy with a look at public
opinion across the region and change
their behavior according to the
realities on the
ground biden is a president under
pressure and in need of a foreign policy
win with low approval ratings record
high inflation and congressional
elections in november biden's meeting
with saudi leaders later in the week he
hopes to convince them to pump more oil
to bring down record fuel prices in the
united states joe biden's trip comes out
of an urgent need to address regional
issues
and a growing desire
to make america's voice clear for what
it is under his administration
the urgent need
yes oil prices inflation the urgent need
are allies who are continuously
uncomfortable with their allies in the
united states and are looking for
alternatives
but while biden seeks to project
american influence with his trip
failure to accomplish any significant
foreign policy achievements could
backfire and underscore just the
opposite the declining presence and
power in the middle east of the united
states
kimberly hellcat al jazeera doha